would be difficult for people who've
done a lot to fight this virus
already but he thinks it's necessary to
stop the spread that's ultimately going
to be up to governor cuomo whether or
not they go forward
with those drastic measures this virus
is of course now infiltrating nfl locker
patriots keeps game with most punks
tonight players from both teams tested
positive including the star quarterback
cam newton
and the titan steelers game was pushed
back several weeks and now
20 people in the titans organization
have become protected
here in new york city um
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
do
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
to
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
me
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
do
[Music]
this
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
do
[Music]
do
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
do
[Music]
do
[Music]
do
[Music]
[Music]
do
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
good morning sorry for the
delay i pride myself on my punctuality
uh but some of the issues that we are
going to discuss today
we were just working on resolving uh and
that's the reason for the delay from my
far right mr gareth rhodes
to his left dr james melatrus
to my right melissa de rosa secretary of
the governor to my left
dr howard zucker health commissioner
extraordinaire
uh to his left the ever smiling and
jovial
rob mika budget director
thank you and again apologize for being
late today is day one
219 but it feels like just yesterday
that this started
doesn't it have that same freshness
and energy groundhog day remember that
movie groundhog day
these are the numbers for today
again we're looking at two different
universes now
it's a little different than the past
we're looking at the statewide numbers
and we are hyper focused on what we call
hot spots
where was the first hot spot in the
united states of america
trivia contest
thank you michelle yee you win
three questions today we had the first
hotspot cluster in the united states new
rochelle new york
so we know this well
uh with over sampling in the hot spots
and with testing all across the state
the 20 hotspot zip codes 5.5
okay our hot spot
zip codes are where many states
are right now and you'll see
it in some of the numbers statewide
positivity rate
is 1.01
outside of the hotspot zip codes one
percent
is an unbelievably low
infection rate uh and
it's as we're going into the fall i
believe it's going to be
practically unsustainable but it's
remarkable that we're that low
right now if you roll
in the hot spot zip codes which now
distorts
the balance of the sample uh it's 1.2
number of deaths eight they are in our
thoughts and prayers statewide
hospitalization 636 icu 149 statewide
intubation 70.
context first we're coming into the fall
we have been told since early march
beware the fall beware of the fall
weather gets colder more people move
indoors
flu season schools open
schools opening are almost
a predictor of increased infection rate
college's opening turned out to be more
problematic
than we thought college is opening
suny's doing a great job
that's why dr jim milanres is here today
if suny was not doing a great job
dr jim milagris would not be here today
that's how you know that so the fall
is a challenging period as we know and
we expect to see
the infection rate go up in the fall
context all over the globe
the infection rate is going up all over
the globe countries that were doing
remarkably well
are now seeing spikes usa
overall is going up israel has a real
problem eu
has a real problem canada has a problem
argentina has a problem the uk
has a problem and the uk
remember they were up they were down
they're up again
you look across the nation states
are all going up so context
be where the fall has been right
new york is the outlier
in all of these international
and national uh trajectories
we are the exception to the rule
this is the one situation where we want
to be
the exception to the rule right
other states up other countries up
that in and of itself is a complicating
factor
because new york state is not
hermetically sealed we put a quarantine
in effect
i know but people still drive in it's
still water through a screen
people are still coming in on flights
international flights
people in texas are coming in people in
california are coming in
people in new jersey are coming in so
that's an added uh problem for us
if you look at the hot spot infection
rate yesterday
western new york is a hot spot
uh yesterday was a good day 1.2
broom has a hot spot uh came out of a
pub restaurant
but broome has a hot spot orange county
rockland county brooklyn nassau
could be on there with a hot spot
in one section of nassau
these clusters have to be attacked
picture that map as a map of dried grass
and picture those hot spots as
a as embers
within the field of dry grass
okay that's how i think of it
the only course
is to run to those embers
and stamp them out
immediately and dramatically
that's why i don't sleep at night
so you have to attack the clusters how
do you attack the clusters
testing testing testing testing
get the facts follow the data
contact tracing off the testing
testing in itself doesn't tell you
anything just that you have a problem
contact tracing helps you solve
the problem and enforcement
enforcement oh
that's so harsh enforcement
yeah it's not enforcement is kind
you know why because enforcement saves
lives
that's what enforcement does lack of
enforcement is not kind
i believe that i believe that
and i have said that from day one and
the state has been bullish on this
and it has worked it's worked it's not
like i'm putting forth a proposition
enforcement works any rule is only as
good as the enforcement
don't speed are you enforcing it
don't litter are you enforcing it
any rule is only as good as the
enforcement
especially when it's a rule that people
don't want to follow
seat belts only as good as you enforce
it don't text and drive
only as good as you enforce it
i say to people when i see them texting
and driving
i say to them i pull up i roll down my
window
i say hi you are texting and driving
that is a violation of the law i know
because i passed that law it's only as
good as the enforcement
when new york tough what's within tough
smart follow the data
follow the analytics disciplined do the
enforcement
stick to the rules stick to what's
working
i've said this 100 times
but at this point in my life i've said
everything 100 times
too many local governments are not doing
enforcement
warnings are not
enforcement
put a mask on or i will take it you is
not enforcement
store owner you're not supposed to have
this many people in your store
we are past that everybody knows the
rules
you don't have to pull over a car today
and say you know you're not supposed to
text and drive
that they know that they know that
what you wind up saying is
i got away with it we've been saying you
get away with
it for too long
and we have lived through this
repeatedly this was bars and restaurants
how many times did i come before you and
say bars and restaurants are a problem
we have gatherings in front of bars and
restaurants local governments have to do
the enforcement
week after week after week and it got
worse and it got worse and it got worse
i then said forget it i give up
the state government will do bars and
restaurants
and we put together a task force we did
over a thousand violations and you know
what
compliance with bars and restaurants is
markedly better than it has been when
was the last time any of you wrote a
story about
bars and restaurants and gatherings in
front of bars and restaurants
why because the owners know they'll lose
their license
oh that's tough no we saved
lives i believe that we saved lives
new york city has clusters
queens brooklyn
we also have clusters akin to this
orange rockland a little bit in nassau
i just got off the telephone with mayor
de blasio controller stringer
council speaker johnson uft president uh
mike mulgrew
uh we had a very good conversation uh it
was a collaborative positive
conversation
it's a complex situ situation
works on a number of levels there are a
number of issues
and we talk through them
we have clusters where
the viral infection rate is higher
about three percent four percent
where does the virus mainly
transmit dr zirco was on the phone we
asked him that question
schools which are also the place where
different communities come
together right
so my child goes to a private school
your child goes to a public school but
our children
are on the same hockey team on the same
soccer team
or they play together in the playground
schools can be locations
of transmissions religious gatherings
especially in these communities
new rochelle first hot spot
was an orthodox jewish man
who went to a temple hundreds of people
and then a wedding hundreds of people
uh orthodox jewish gatherings
often are very very large
and we've seen what one person can do in
a group
look at this rose garden with the
president by the way
outdoor event oh those are safe outdoor
events
no no no safer than indoor
nobody ever said safe safer than indoor
and look at that growing list of people
at a presidential rose garden event who
were theoretically tested before they
came
in how many people could have been
infected
one two and look at the spread
in the rose garden you know
what happens here you've seen it over
and over again
third of public spaces these are
basically in priority order
fourth are businesses where
consumers may interact but that is way
down on the list
relatively and
the key to all of these areas is
enforcement
all of them we have rules for all these
areas we have rules
for all these areas in place now well
then how is it
increasing because people are not
following the rules
that's why
on schools my number one concern
has always been schools i said to the
parents of this state
i will not send i will not allow
your child to be sent to any school that
i would not send my child
period and you have my personal word on
that
i've spoken to thousands of parents who
have called up and said i'm worried
about sending my child to school
i said i won't allow a school to open
that i wouldn't send my child to that's
my test
on the schools in these areas
not all of them have been tested
so we don't have data on all of the
schools
in these hot spot clusters
that troubles me
and uh on the telephone call we were all
basically
in agreement they have sampled some
schools
in the clusters but not all the schools
and these are the hotspot clusters right
so if you have to prioritize testing
you want to go to these schools first
because you know they are in hotspot
clusters
so some schools in those clusters we
have not yet done
testing on
better safe than sorry i would not send
my child
to a school in a hot spot cluster that
has not been tested
where i did not have proof that the
infection rate was low
in that school i would not send my child
i am not going to recommend or allow
any new york city family to send their
child to a school that i wouldn't send
my child
we're going to close the schools in
those areas tomorrow
and that's that
religious gatherings
the uh city's proposal does not
close religious institutions
we know religious institutions
have been a problem
we know mass gatherings are the super
spreader events
we know there have been mass gatherings
going on in concert
with religious institutions in these
communities
for weeks four
weeks i don't mean
little violations
you're only supposed to have 50 they had
55.
i'm talking about you're only supposed
to have 50 outdoors
they had 1 000
these are pictures from
the past couple of weeks
and these are just emblematic
you've all seen pictures like this
for weeks
what did you think was going to happen
what did you think was going to happen
religious institutions our mass
gatherings
and raise the greatest
potential it's schools and its large
mass gatherings
schools frankly because they're students
and that's where
our heart goes our priority goes but in
terms of numbers
it's large gatherings and
large religious gatherings are large
gatherings
these have been going on for weeks
you don't see masks and you see
clear violation of social distancing
when were these pictures from well one
of the
one on the right is more recent overlap
okay but there in the recent past
so this has been going on for weeks
we've been talking about it for weeks
if we're going to keep religious
institutions
open it can only be
with two conditions one
the community must agree
whether it's the jewish community
whether we're talking about black
churches
whether we're talking about roman
catholic churches
the religious community has to agree to
the rules
and they have to agree that they are
going to follow
the rules and they have to agree
that they are going to be a full partner
in the enforcement
of the rules that's
condition one i'm going to meet with
members of the
ultra orthodox community tomorrow i want
to have that
conversation directly myself
this cannot happen again if you do not
agree
to enforce the rules then we'll close
the institutions down
i am prepared to do that
second after we receive the agreement
an agreement is only as good as the
enforcement
we have to have real enforcement
in these clusters and the other
statewide clusters
the enforcement will help the community
if the rule is no more than 50 percent
of the people in a black church
i want someone at that door when fifty
percent
enter the church
a person there who says
uh to the pastor
you agreed to follow the rules that's 50
percent
that's it or we close it down
it does not work without enforcement
but both of those conditions have to be
in place
and if i do not have the agreement
from the religious community directly
as a starting point then
we will close down the religious
institutions
if they do agree to do it in partnership
then i want a real enforcement capacity
we're not going to make the same mistake
twice
tomorrow i'm going to meet with the
larger
congregations new york city rocklin
orange nassau and have that conversation
that's step one
if we get past step one then we need
enforcement in place
enforcement is enforcement
i've said this to you i have this
conversation with local officials
all day long well we
we issue warnings
that's not enforcement well we do public
education
that's not enforcement the
there is no person in the state of new
york who needs you to tell them at this
point
you must wear a mask they know
they must wear a mask there's no need
for public education
find me the person who says i never
heard that
really you have to wear a mask i never
heard it
find me the person in the state who says
that
enforcement is enforcement okay
uh new york city only did 26
enforcement actions enforcement
is here's a violation
new york city deployed a thousand people
for days
three days a thousand people for three
days
is what is
24 000 personnel hours
24 000 personal hours you only did 26
enforcement actions that's not enforced
enforcement
we have to be more aggressive i
understand
that it's in politic
uh i understand the sensitivity in the
community now
but i also understand you'll
you will see people die if we don't do
more enforcement i also understand that
we have
learned this experience before
this is the bars and restaurant story
week after week after week we have to do
the enforcement nobody's doing the
enforcement
week after week after week nothing
changes
the state took it over i did 1200
enforcement
actions 228 immediate license
replications
just on bars and restaurants
1200 now
i happy about doing 1200 enforcement
actions
no
immediate license revocation is very
difficult
that business basically closes people
lose their jobs
you don't want to do this but life is
options my friends
you don't do this the virus spreads
people die
you tell me which is the nice and kind
and responsible
course of conduct 1200 enforcement
actions just on bars and restaurants
that's enforcement
the state is going to take over
the enforcement oversight in all the
hotspot clusters
okay
local governments will need to provide
us
with personnel but
the state will take over the enforcement
with the local personnel i do not have
enough state
personnel to supplement
every local police department
in the state to give you an idea we have
about five thousand state
troopers there are about 35 000 nypd
okay
most of this enforcement is also going
to be done by health department
officials
other agency type officials
i said from day one to the local
officials i understand this is all
tough stuff and politicians like to make
people happy
as a general rule i like to make people
happy as a general rule too
i just have a superseding rule which is
i like to keep people alive
i'd rather you be alive and angry
at me than uh
have people happy with me i'm elected to
do a job and be responsible and that's
what i want to do
i said from day one blame me
blame me you have to revoke a bar
owner's license blame me
we have to close the temple because it's
over 50
i'll do it we have to close a roman
catholic church
i'll do it i had to close the st
patrick's day parade
i did it i'll do it
but none of these rules are going to
make
a dawn if you don't have the enforcement
another issue that came up on the phone
which is right
targeting by zip codes
is imperfect the virus doesn't travel by
zip codes
neighborhoods uh and communities aren't
organized by
zip codes zip codes can be
[Music]
arbitrary and can leave out
the some communities that are infected
zip codes can include communities
that have a low infection rate
this is a zip code in brooklyn
the white areas are inside the zip code
but we have the infection rate by
address you have areas in that zip code
that aren't infected
you then have areas outside the zip code
that are infected
so the zip code is a template
uh is rough justice but only rough
justice
and we can refine that
uh takes uh some
review and analysis but look at the
actual
cases that you have again by address
and make sure you're including
the relevant zone not just a zip code
you have to go a little bigger you go a
little bigger
you have to if you don't have an
infection rate in certain communities
uh don't include those infection rates
so the zip codes
uh as a starting place
but we then want to have a team of
uh epidemiologists and
demographics people actually look at the
maps
and where the infection rate is and make
sure
where where we're drawing the right
circle or the right borders
and the controller raised that point
and it's a good point and health
officials agree
when we did new rochelle
we did a circle
every other state every other country
does a political subdivision a county
a city a town so
the zip codes are not the best
template to use and we want to refine
that template
for example we're closing schools in zip
codes
but the school district is different
than the zip code so just because the
school is located in that zip code
doesn't mean the students come from that
zip code
the catchment area can go the opposite
direction from the zip code
but uh right now
that's the best we have with the new
york city data but we're going to refine
this
non-essential businesses public spaces
remember as mass gatherings public
spaces
schools should close but we need to have
the right template
designed before we can do that with full
accuracy
the only action we're taking today on
this data
we are using the zip codes to close
those schools tomorrow
if we expand the regions and that then
includes
other schools we'll then notify people
as soon as we know
but for today or we have other zip code
is the zip code data so it's the schools
in those zip codes
and as we refine it we'll let you know
so in total
schools close tomorrow
i'm going to be meeting with the
orthodox community tomorrow
uh see if they will agree to live and
abide by the rules
and advocate compliance
if the rabbi advocates compliance
that would be a very positive start if
the communities don't agree with the
rules
which is possible i had some
conversations where
some religious leaders believe they have
hurt immunity
which is not true some people believe
have followed politics and think that
masks are ineffective and this is all a
hoax
that's not true but if they don't agree
then the state will take action
if they do agree and
we have the ability to enforce
then we will go with reduced
guidance 50 rules
uh primarily outdoors etc
we're going to do statewide enforcement
states supervised with local resources
but enforcement has to be enforcement
we need uh better templates
geographic templates than zip codes
we also need better data on
these schools in these hotspots zip
codes
more testing faster testing so we find
out exactly where we are
and we need to establish criteria for
reopening
when do the areas reopen
what testing data what percent over what
period of time
that has to be established so in closing
new york city is not unique we have this
all across the state
again we started with the first hot spot
and
uh it's going to continue it is the way
of the world
it's the way this virus moves
it starts in a cluster it always starts
in a cluster
wherever and the question always becomes
can you stop it in the cluster
can you tamp out the embers
before it's a fire out of control that's
always the question that was the
question in wuhan
china could you get to wuhan and stamp
it out
before it spread that was the question
in new rochelle
and we did stamp it out in new rochelle
by the way
and every state is dealing with it but
uh it's a statewide issue
it's testing and it's enforcement that's
what we're down to
we're new york tough smart disciplined
just to reiterate the fall is perilous
we have to stay vigilant
when we talk about one percent
i understand that it is
a hyper ambitious goal
you have to remember we were at 20
infection rate at one time
uh and i understand that we are
surrounded
by higher infection rates
new jersey is 2.1
they were three last week
okay connecticut is 1.3
they were 1.5 and connecticut has always
been a relatively easier situation
than new york i'm envious
of my friend governor ned lamont
pennsylvania is at 7.9 percent
we have people coming in and out of here
every day from these states
we have people flying in from other
countries
so one percent
hyper ambitious unrealistic
keep the bar high uh
raise the goal and we do the best we can
but i'm also realistic
and these are the facts that surround us
that's why right now you take out our
hot spots
we have one of the lowest infection
rates in the united states of america
and that is the gold standard and that's
what we want to try to achieve
even if it is not fully realistic
but new yorkers have done an amazing job
highest infection rate
at one time lowest in the nation
god bless new yorkers and i want to make
sure as governor i'm doing everything i
can
to honor and fulfill their sacrifice
uh and their toughness
uh and their love for each other and
we're doing that
questions on the school specifically
give a sense of how many that is total
in brooklyn what will the duration be
and why did you think
now is not the time to really go after
the essential businesses i mean you
think you could do that as soon as this
week
essential businesses are like number
four
in the spreader priority right
schools mass gatherings
uh religious institutions especially in
these
communities public spaces
uh businesses but the businesses are not
mass
spreaders you know you're talking about
small stores we're not talking about
large box stores in these communities
right we're talking about
small stores the difference whether you
had six patrons
or eight patrons at any given time
um and we want to
the businesses will be really affected
by the lines you draw
and we're going to i believe we can draw
better lines than a zip code
and before we create confusion
uh on one side of the street you're open
one side of the street you're closed
why well the zip code line is on this
side of the street not that side of the
street
uh let's get the right template
and uh then we'll take those actions
but the big generators
schools it's children
there are about do you remember the
numbers of schools we said were in these
areas
mike said it how many were tested
28 28 or 30 or like 180 or something
like that
many of the schools in these clusters
just have not been tested yet
and that gives me concern and they are
possible transmission places
and then it's going to be the mass
gatherings and the religious
institutions and those are the pictures
right that's what it is
it is those super spreading situations
and that's what we have to get a handle
on
are you talking about yeshiva and other
private schools in addition to the
public yes
the mayor had proposed wednesday to
close the schools you're moving that up
one day what is the reason for that his
argument was
we're just about through with giving
every child that in-person day in the
blended model
wednesday is when it makes sense we had
a phone call now
uh well
mike mulgrew recommended it speaker
recommended it
the controller recommended it i think
what was the determinative fact
was there has not been testing in those
schools
some of the schools in the hot spot zip
codes have been tested
but some have not how can you send
children
into a school in a hot spot zip code
when you know that you don't have any
information as to whether or not it's
safe
yeah except i wasn't involved right i
had the conversation today
so i can't move any faster than this
you're not closing the schools in orange
and rocklin the other hot spots just the
new york city schools why
we may close those schools we don't have
the same
level of of problem but i'm going to be
speaking to those community
leaders also tomorrow because it is
it's roughly the same situation
if the religious leaders do not agree
to abide by these rules uh
then we will close the religious
institutions
period if they agree
uh i will only go forward
if i know we have a state supervised
enforcement action
because i've seen this movie and you've
seen this movie
26 enforcement actions is not
enforcement
uh and i understand it's difficult
but i want a person monitoring
the attendance in a temple in a black
church
in a catholic church and if the rules
are violated
then action has to be taken at that
moment
and that enforcement has to be in place
the challenge is
i don't have on the state side
enough people to say we'll do all the
enforcement
that would be easy and i would do that
in a heartbeat
uh i didn't even have enough people to
do
the bars and restaurants task force
we took people from all over i have
environmental inspectors
on that task force you know but
it also proved it worked and
both conditions have to be in place if
we're going to allow the
religious institutions to stay open if
one or two doesn't happen then we'll
close them i don't have a
will the problem be involved in
enforcing social distancing restrictions
um among individuals or purely through
this task force
on businesses schools religious it's
individuals but you know you want to
prioritize
your impact mass gatherings
have the most potential to do a super
spreader right
rose garden new rochelle so
certainly mass gatherings first if i'm
an investigator and i'm out there and i
want to make a difference in the world
mass gatherings mess gatherings at
religious institutions
mass gatherings in parks by the way
mass gatherings of young people
at parks in front of nyu
right college kids
coming out to 300 to party
those are all mass gatherings and
uh that's that's a
priority for compliance
uh schools priority
and then you go down with businesses
uh and then individuals so would they be
authorized then to ticket people
who are walking on the street without
masks for example oh they are now
but zach for them to enforce it in that
way you say it's not the highest
priority but
it is now you walk down the street
without a mask you're within six feet of
a person
you are in violation of the law
yes and they should be enforcing it now
so you should not that question should
not be a question
the answer is of course nypd should be
enforcing it now
new york city department of health
should be enforcing it now
you should have no question in your mind
that if you walk down the street and
you're not wearing a mask and a police
officer sees you you're going to be
ticketed
doesn't orange county county have higher
infection rates
it depends it depends on where
there's not higher
well uh that's what we're going to be
talking about
and there's some disparity uh in what
the infection rates are
and we want to drill down on the data
but it's the same basic conversation
we're having here
give me one second do you believe you
have the legal authority to close down
religious institutions
court order are you doing that
we believe we have the legal authority
we will assert the legal authority
we have been sued by the religious
organizations our legal authority was
upheld i don't like getting into a
litigious
situation with the religious community
i have enough answer questions that i
have to answer when i get to the pearly
gates
i want to also be questioned as to why i
was sued
by the catholic church or uh
the jewish community for closing temples
i have enough issues on my plate
uh but uh yes we believe we have the
legal authority do you want to say
something
no i would just say louise you have to
remember back so when we did new york on
paws
back on march 20th we banned all mass
gatherings more than 10 people
and we closed all non-essential
businesses it was the mass gathering
rule
that was upheld and so technically
during that period of time individuals
could walk into a religious institution
and pray
but you couldn't have more than 10
people in a religious institution
regardless of occupancy
at any given time what changed was when
we began to
do the phased reopening and we started
to say that businesses could have 50
capacity we said houses of worship could
have 30 percent 33
capacity the lawsuit was over whether or
not it was fair that in a
religious institution you were taking a
different standard than any other
business
and the court at the time went with the
businesses but what the governor is
describing is if we're moving into a
situation
where we're indiscriminately saying a
mass gathering number
in a certain region based on infection
rate would be lowered
let's call it 10 people i'm not saying
that's what it's going to be but just
for example say
10 people then you're not saying a
religious institution is being treated
differently than any other institution
because if the law would be applied
evenly throughout does that make sense
a picture of the two can you put up the
picture of the uh
uh the two congregations again silence
are you leaning against shutting them up
shutting them down and closing them
are you leaning against the mayor's
supposed to work what
on the non-essential businesses
also on the schools uh
we all agree we need to do a better
template than a zip code a zip code
is not the best
uh definition of
the applicable zone right
you have information beyond the zip code
level
you have addresses you have census tract
data
so if you have to draw a
i use the word containment zone in new
rochelle i got into all sorts of trouble
if you have to uh circumscribe an
area make sure you have the right
boundaries
and before you make a determination
about essential businesses or not
make sure you have the right geographic
area
because you will be closing businesses
and if you don't do it right it'll just
be arbitrary and capricious and then
they'll bring you into court
and they'll say it's just because i
happen to be in the zip code and one
side of the street
the deli is open on the other side of
the street the deli is closed
what sense does that make uh all you're
doing is bringing the people
across the street so what is the best
area uh if once we have that
done then uh
i don't have a problem with closing the
essential businesses
that you determine for how long
by what data etc
but even all of this comes back
to do you have the enforcement capacity
to enforce any of this all these great
rules
yeah but do you have the enforcement
capacity
so uh
i know we're giving you a lot first
action close the schools tomorrow
use the zip codes because that's all you
have for now
if you come up with a different template
and i'm sorry when you come up with a
different template if it includes
additional schools
include additional schools meet with the
orthodox community see if they will
agree to live by the rules
if they do then we need to put in
together a statewide enforcement task
force and the local governments have to
give me enough personnel to make it work
and that will be statewide including new
york city
then redraw the geographic
uh boundaries see what's in and see
what's out
uh then put that out there and
that's all so why do you think mayor de
blasio has not been able to pull the
trigger
on enforcing these things you have to
ask the mayor
i know you are asking me and that's why
i'm saying
you have to ask the mayor uh
look i think
it's not just a new york city issue it's
local governments
plus or minus some are very aggressive
by the way do a great job
but some have been very reluctant and
that's why i had to do the bar and
restaurant task force i mean how many
times did you sit here
and i saw the uh
skepticism in your face when you'd say
here he goes again
with his bar and restaurant rant
but yes how many weeks did we say look
at the crowds look at the pictures
look at all the young people in front of
the bar do something they did nothing
part of it is the environment you know
uh
the nypd tension with the community
uh do they want to engage in this kind
of activity
then you go to the mayor's been using
the sheriff the sheriff's office is 150
people what do you think 150 people are
going to do
uh i mean it's just not enough and then
you have the political overlay
you're dealing with government saying to
religions
you shouldn't have uh
more than x people in your church or
your mosque
or your temple that's a politically
uncomfortable situation
you know i have to say to the orthodox
community tomorrow
uh if you're not willing to live with
these uh rules
then i'm going to close the synagogues
i have had a 30-year relationship with
the orthodox community
it goes back to my father
uh i have a very close personal
relationship
with him this is the last thing
i want to do forget the politics
i don't care about that anymore
personally
i don't want to have this conversation
it's a difficult conversation
and you're right on the line of
government
uh intrusion on religion
so it's hard i didn't want to close down
1000 bars put people out of work you
know it's hard
but i know in new york city's case
26 enforcement actions
that with with this rampant
ongoing violation
you think 26 enforcement actions was
going to stop it
no
the state is going to oversee the
enforcement
with local personnel what does that mean
and why it's going to be different than
what you just described
i would have what we did with the bars
in the restaurants
is i used state personnel from all
across the state
and it was run by the state police in
the sla
here we'll have a task force put
together
run by the department of health and the
state police
and local governments will need to
assign
people to that task force who are
supervised by that task force
deputized by that task force
to give out state summonses
uh as directed by the supervisors
of that task force right so
you can be a nassau county department of
health official
you are assigned to the task force
i'm the state person running the task
force i say you're going to be stationed
in front of saint peter's church
the capacity is 150. you stand at the
front door
when they go over 75
you close the door and call me
and if you have any problem this state
police officer is down the block
and he'll come help you that's your job
you are from the department of health
but you are assigned
nassar county but you're assigned to a
state task force so the state
is telling the local officials where
have been
say one more time i'm sorry the state is
telling the local officials where today
no the state is determining where to be
primarily based on the hotspot clusters
right here in new york city we
knew where the problems were we knew it
so we're all looking at the same areas
because we all have the same data
on the zip codes and the communities
we just haven't been aggressive enough
on the enforcement
and uh i've said from day one
blame me i'm willing uh to do the
enforcement
i have a different political perspective
i think it's kind
and right and responsible as opposed to
harsh
and i'm going to make enemies and
the state task force is going to do it
but i don't have enough
people i don't have enough personnel so
i need them to assign me
personnel i'm just wondering if the
locals didn't do it before
what makes you think they're going to do
it now oh because they're not doing it
in their name
it's my name that they're doing
and that makes all the difference
oh yes because there's no political
recriminations to them
you know i'm going to say to the
orthodox community tomorrow if
you don't agree
[Music]
then we will have to close down
[Music]
the your religious institutions i'm
going to have to say that to the
black ministers that's not a comfortable
conversation
just to punch the governor's point so
just so we're all clear section 20 of
the executive law regarding emergency
response delegates the authority on
enforcement in an emergency to the
locality so let's just use that as the
baseline
to go on the governor's point on the sla
what was happening a lot over the summer
was everyone was seeing on social media
reports of bars and restaurants and
drive-in concerts whatever it may be in
clear violation
of the rules that we put into place in
order to keep the virus contained in new
york
we would reach out to the local health
departments local governments say what
are you doing about this
and politically it was very difficult
for them oh my friend's cousin owns that
bar
this person i know owns that restaurant
it was just this one time
and so the governor put together the sla
task force the hope being from the sla
task force was that we would go after
individual bad actors before having to
blanket punish an entire industry
so rather than in that moment in july
and august say we're closing all bars
and restaurants indoor outdoor
everything we tried to surgically go
after the individual bad
actors and it was incredibly effective
to the governor's point you now see
dramatic change in compliance at the
same time
my phone was ringing off the hook
robert's phone is ringing off the hook
from local politicians
state legislators assembly and senators
in these areas
saying you closed down my friend's
brother's bar you're being gratuitous
it was just one violation you're going
after and finding these people
and we said yeah we are because we lived
through mass graves on hard island and
we lived through sirens in this city
and we lived through death and we're not
doing it again so we will take it over
and when they say
well we're upset you can say well the
governor's office is terrible
they're going to continue doing it and
they're going to continue doing it no
matter what we say so you better just
follow the rules
and we have seen a dramatic change in
compliance as a result
and that's what we're trying to
accomplish here let me do it another way
for you
just turn the picture a little bit so i
don't have every local official calling
me this afternoon
the first
many local governments have done this
very well
second this is a very different
situation
because this is a state law
that has been delegated to them
to enforce state law
which is a new state law delegated to
them to enforce they
don't close down religious institutions
it's not what they do they don't close
down bars
they don't close down restaurants they
don't close down
uh driving concerts
they don't tell people to wear masks
they don't tell people you can't gather
100 people in a park they have never
done this before
it's not what they do
covet we pass these new state laws
you are delegated to enforce them it's
your job
we've never done this before it's not
what we do
my local police don't close down bars
and we don't tell people to wear masks i
know you've never done it before but you
have to do it
we don't go into a church and say you're
violating the 50
rule close the church we don't do that
i know but you have to do it now
that's for the bureaucracy to accept
that
and pivot and do it and these are all
difficult
laws think about it you're a local
politician
pick one close temples close
mosques close schools close catholic
churches
you know no thank you how long the
duration would be
for the schools for example would you
want testing in the schools to indicate
when they could reopen or is it the
community at large
within the zip code it may be both we
don't know
and that's what we want to establish the
state has
dr zucker's going to work with uh the
city and some other
outside experts to make that
determination
on the boundaries like we know of two
concerts that are planned in brooklyn
this week
in the ultra orthodox community are you
going to close down larger venues this
week well first of all
it shouldn't be happening anyway
period it violates the existing
law
that's what only you have to enforce the
law
statewide i've gone through this in
suffolk they had
a music concert fundraiser
uh in one of the towns on in the
hamptons
uh you can't have
a concert mass gathering
today you can't
i don't care what zone you're in you
can't do it
lazio yesterday uh announced a plan ask
for your approval
set a presser for 12 today you all
scheduled one for 10 30 then 11 45
i understand you had to meet with them
first or feed over the phone
discuss your team and his team but i
wonder if you could explain to the
public
why you couldn't have a joint
announcement a joint
press conference we in the world could
ask you all these questions together
and have a united front i think a lot of
people
have a lot of frustration about that
division can you explain it to them
uh no you have a federal government you
have a state government
you have a city government uh
you have county governments this is a
situation where by law
is governed by state law the mayor said
that yesterday
the mayor said i have a plan
i'm going to propose it to the state
okay now i have to review it i have to
see what the speaker says i have to see
what the hasidic community says i have
to see what the police say
i have to see what the controller thinks
uh i have to see what my health
officials think it's a complex
issue right and
he did announce it so people now want to
know
it's caused a lot of aggravation my
phone has been ringing off the hook
the city community is very concerned
parents are very concerned
what's happening what do you know so i
want people to know as soon as possible
especially your schools are closed
tomorrow so you can figure out what to
do tomorrow
and this is uh
the most recent update
and i spoke to him about it
i spoke to him mulgrew the controller
the speaker and this is what
uh we agreed we would do this is the
plan of action
you were hearing it as soon as i could
get it to you
governor what kind of uh testing going
forward do you want to see in schools
you said there's not enough going on and
the city
at least the city schools were doing
monthly random testing a certain
percentage
do you want to see something more than
that and then how about
the yeshivas or religious schools in
these areas do you want to see more
specific testing
i would say two things i'll say three
things
first uh i probably know
more testing than any non-testing expert
in the state and i know more about
testing than i ever wanted to know
and we do more testing than any state in
the united states
but i know what i don't know and i want
to get the input
we have the best global experts that we
work with i want to hear what they think
but number two if you know you have
a hot spot zip code test that
school test that school
uh any if you're gonna send a child
into a school that you know
is in a hot spot
you have to in my opinion you have to
test at school
before you would ever send a child into
a zone
that you already know is a hot spot
second random monthly
what is the interval between the tests
in other words does that mean you're
going to random you have 30 days
31 days let's say is it all in the first
week
maybe all in the last week is it
uh spaced out every week what are the
intervals
between the test because this goes like
this
right well we did a test
on day one but then we didn't test again
until day
10 and lo and behold from day one to day
10 it went up
four points no i think
random is fine monthly
i don't know what that means monthly
uh does that mean you could just do it
once a month
uh you know i understand daily i
understand weekly
i don't really understand uh random
monthly because it sounds like it's
a month if you're saying it could
possibly be a month between tests
that that doesn't work for me i can tell
you
i would not say i would not accept that
plan from my school
will there be an impact to indoor and
outdoor dining in these uh
cluster areas there could be there could
be we're reviewing
do you think it'll be this week yeah we
need to come up with the template
because i don't want to confuse
businesses you're in you are out you're
in
there's been enough of that you know uh
when government comes up with a plan
stick to the plan don't change the plan
uh it suggests the people confusion
and incompetence uh so
what's the right geographic template uh
what's an essential business now
what's the indoor dining rule now what's
the mass gathering rule
now and then how do you enforce it
you're the governor of the state the
mayor is the mayor of the city
that doesn't preclude you from speaking
together
does it why can't two of you as
friends subjects come together
one message from one place instead of
these different voices from different
places
i look i have i've been with the mayor
many times
he has a schedule i have a schedule i
wanted to get you
the information quickly i didn't put out
this plan
he did so
if anything you'd want to ask him why
didn't you
propose a plan to the state and work it
out
first and then just announce a final
plan
as opposed to announcing a proposed plan
that the state then had to react to
uh i don't know you know why you sit in
that seat
i don't know people have their own
styles in their own uh
their own way of doing things but that's
all it is
speaking of sitting in seats but you all
are a few feet away
indoors and not wearing a mask i wonder
if you could speak to the
the mask wearing culture in this room in
your office
and and what it says uh as you talk
about the need for
enforcing laws uh and being consistent
uh what it's what it's telling to those
communities whom i
i feel probably pretty safe to say are
tweeting even as we speak
about your presence together uh
without masses we have sat in these
seats
six feet apart socially distanced
without masks
since covert started the rule
is six feet apart
and that's what we do this state has
been a model
of mask wearing we were the first state
to mandate masks in the united states of
america
we have do done more advertising for
masks than any state
in the nation we've done national public
service announcements on mass squaring
i've been the most outspoken governor
against the president for not
mass wearing i've been the most
outspoken governor against the cdc
and nih and the vice president for not
condemning
the president's failure to wear masks i
visited cities
all across the country and advocated
mask wearing i said that this nation
and its health officials made a terrible
mistake
by telling this country early on not to
wear masks
surgeon general tweeted they are
unnecessary
whenever i am in a situation where i
should wear a mask i do wear a mask
don't confuse people by putting forth
your own mask wearing rules
do that with your family if you are six
feet apart you do not need
to wear a mask let alone
these people were all tested on
basically a daily basis
what about aerosols though isn't there
new evidence that the virus spreads
through the air
the rule is six feet social distancing
do you want to change the rule
who's determining this rule you've said
that the cdc can't be trusted
for public health guidance but there is
lots of new research that shows the
virus can spread
the cdc's rule is six feet
the state law is six feet
if there's new data and we should come
up with a new law
then the cdc could do that the
department of health could do that but
the law
is six feet that is the law
the law is a mask the law
is not a helmet if new data comes out
and says you should wear a helmet then
we'll have a helmet law
the law says a mask not ear muffs
because we don't believe
the virus goes in your ear maybe
somebody will do an article
saying it can invade your ear and then
we'll have a new mask
with earmuffs last question
what is your level of concern that the
outbreak is going to
continue to increase what's the stop if
we do
close outdoor dining indoor gardening
let's just tell people that live in hot
spots
nothing nothing nothing
which is why the health officials are
very worried about how you draw the
lines
because what the health officials will
tell you is if you don't draw the lines
correctly
you will be taking the infected people
in the zip code
and sending them to the next community
to have outdoor dining because their
indoor
their outdoor dining is closed and you
can actually be spreading
the virus that's why the geographic
template is very important
this has never been done before
every other government closes
subdivisions
the entire city the entire county
brooklyn closes now theoretically
you want to drive into manhattan you can
drive into manhattan
but you have to drive into manhattan or
take a train into manhattan you want to
go into queens
to eat you can go to queens but you have
to go to queens
you get this small area
you just walk across the street you walk
two blocks
and we were trying to contain you
that's why new rochelle what we did
was a one mile circle
and it had a margin around it
so in other words the circle was wide
enough
where there was a buffer between
the infected community and the
non-affected community
um but yeah that is a very real concern
and there's a very real question of
if you do this wrong are you just
spreading inadvertently the virus
so how you draw those lines is very
important
what would enforcement look like then in
that situation
no the enforcement winds up the same you
draw the lines and then the enforcement
is the enforcement
and the enforcement is uh indoor dining
is only supposed to be 25
you have 30 percent you get a ticket uh
it's supposed to be outdoor dining
you know whatever the rules are they
enforce in that template but you're
right
make sure that template is right if
you're saying you don't have to know
data from some schools or not some
schools aren't testing enough they don't
have the adequate capacity
should those scores have been allowed to
reopen in the first place
we didn't say we didn't say no
we didn't say uh inadequate data
there is no data these schools
opened and have done no testing
that was the city plan that the new york
city parents
signed off on and the new york city
teachers union
signed off on they had this
uh random monthly
testing plan
uh but they did not have a provision
that said
if a uh the
the higher infection rate zip codes
uh will be tested first
um so i think
this has been educational for them and
that's something you want to look at
my point is you have no data on these
on some of these schools in these
hotspot zip codes
would you send your child to
school tomorrow
to a school that you knew
had no data on
infection rate but didn't know it was a
hot spot zip code
would you send your child a good answer
right i wouldn't so
that's that's how i do my decision sorry
what group
no state put out guidance
and then the 700 school districts
came up with a plan pursuant to that
guidance
i said 876 times
put the plan on the web let the
teachers union look at it let teachers
look at it let parents look at it let
the reporters
read the plan and report on the plan
and if a savvy reporter sees an obvious
hole
in the plan i'm sure they will write
about it
thank you guys
[Music]
right now in brooklyn i'm told it's
crowded who shouldn't be enforcing that
the city of new york the nypd
the nypd the new york city department of
health
today is in charge of
enforcing the laws
that's what i'm saying
we have these laws everybody knows the
laws
they're not being enforced
they have to be enforced well we have
tension with the police we have tension
over here
i don't want it i get it but if you
don't enforce the law
the virus will spread
so your question is relevant there's an
ongoing activity that violates the law
how is this possible that's why i'm
saying
i want state supervised enforcement
going forward in these clusters because
i
am unhappy statewide
with the enforcement that's been going
on if you had done the enforcement
these things don't happen you saw the
pictures
how did the virus get high that's how
the virus guide hunted
there's no mystery here right
thank you guys
[Music]